And now the old scout master,
Humorist and author, Dave Berry, comes up with a good one every once in a while.
He said this: it always rains on tents.
Rainstorms will travel thousands of miles against prevailing winds for the opportunity to rain
on a tent.
It sounds like Dave's been camping with us a couple of times.
Hey, this is podcast number 194..
Hey
Well, welcome back to the Scout Master Podcast.
This is Clark Greene.
We got a lot lined up today.
Let's take a look in the mailbag.
Oh, we're on Stitchercom.
Did you know that you can access the podcast on any mobile device through Stitcher Smart Radio?
I use that actually to listen to my own podcast and to other podcasts,
And you can find out how to do that at Stitchercom.
You'll find it in the Google App Store and you'll find it in the iTunes App Store too.
Stitcher S-T-I-T-C-H-E-R- Stitcher Smart Radio.
Over on Stitcher this past week, Tool, Matt,
Tool, Matt left us a five star review.
Thank you, Matt.
He said this is the best Scout Leaders podcast, sometimes funny, always useful sometimes.
Oh, come on,
If you're looking for tips to help you be a better Scouter, you found the right place.
Thanks, Matt.
Sure appreciate the kind words.
Rick Brown in Akron, Ohio with PAC 3015 and Troop 310, wrote in to ask:
is there any way to download all of your podcasts?
I'd like to download them all and listen to them while driving to work.
Rick, you can do this by going to scoutmastercgcom.
Look for the link to the podcast archive and there you'll find you can download
all of the past 193 editions of the podcast.
Now, if you follow us on iTunes, you will note that finally, finally,
I figured out how to get more than one podcast on iTunes.
I think there's the 10 past editions up there now.
So we're on our way to fixing iTunes-
Well, at least fixing our podcast on iTunes.
But thanks for getting in touch, Rick, and I hope that helps.
Carl Summer is with PAC 222 in Raleigh, North Carolina.
He said this: I've started listening to the podcast
In podcast one. there's this awesome arrangement of taps.
My brother's in a brass on some that would love to play this arrangement.
Well, Carl boy, that's going back a while.
That particular one you're talking about is called Taps for Maynard,
Referring, of course, to Maynard Ferguson.
It's pretty easy to find, actually, on the music service of your choice, Taps for Maynard.
Terry Dutton is with Troop 16 in Oak Park, Illinois,
and he wrote in to say: I wanted to let you know I've turned your name into a verb.
This weekend I was lucky enough to staff a Scoutmaster
assistant Scoutmaster leader specific training course.
Afterward I was talking with a fellow volunteer who's also a podcast listener.
I mentioned to him that I did a lot of Clark greening during the training.
Oh my, and they didn't throw you out on your ear.
Well, that's good, Terry.
Specifically, when the discussion came to advancement,
one leader said his scouts weren't motivated to sit down and work on requirements.
I pointed out that our goal shouldn't be to do advancement
but to do the Scout program, and advancement will follow as a natural outcome.
The point hit home.
I wanted you to know that your blog and podcast have had a positive impact on my work with Scouts
and I'm happy to pass your influence on to others.
Thanks,
Well, thank you, Terry.
It's always heartening to know that people find all of this useful
And, by the way, you hit that one right out of the park.
Good for you.
This Sunday, November 10, from nine to 10 pm
Eastern Standard Time, is our November Scout Circle.
Scout Circle is a live presentation where you can watch and you can also send in questions,
And this time around this month we will be talking about the Weeblows to Scouts transition.
So go to scoutcircleorg and you'll be able to watch the presentation this Sunday, November 10,
from nine to 10 pm Eastern Standard Time.
So the blog's been a little quieter than usual because we're doing a lot of work behind the scenes.
I will remind you yet again that I've got a new book due to be published within the next couple of weeks.
It's already November, folks, and we're in the final throws of proofreading and referencing
and all of the great stuff that has to happen when you put a book together.
The book's called The Scouting Journey, and keep an eye open because soon we'll be able to do pre-orders for it.
Part of this I'm going to do through the institution of a new backer program,
And this will give you the opportunity to help us out here.
I'll tell you something:
We've had a big uptick in the number of readers and listeners at scoutmastercgcom, which is great news.
That great news is accompanied by the need to upgrade our services,
And that upgrade means we spend more money.
And so keep your eyes open because within the next week or so, I'm going to roll out pre-orders for the new book
and this backer program where you can become a scoutmastercgcom backer,
And we've got some premiums and gifts set up for those folks who are willing to do that.
Within the next week or two, we'll get all that published.
Another reminder, and in tune with the kind of theme of this podcast:
Before long- the first of this coming year, January 1, 2014,- the list of eagle-required merit badges is going to change slightly,
with the addition of cooking as a required merit badge and the new sustainability merit badge as an alternative to environmental science.
Now I've got a post about this with an infographic at scoutmastercgcom.
If you go to the website, you'll see in the upper left hand corner a little graphic: changes to eagle-required merit badges.
Click on that for the full post and the infographic that accompanies it,
Just to remind everybody about the change to eagle-required merit badges that is coming.
That doesn't happen very often and it might catch you unawares,
So make sure to check that post out.
In this podcast, we're going to answer a few questions about eagle-scout
and we're going to start that in scoutmastership in seven minutes or less
by discussing what actually makes an eagle-scout,
And I've got a couple of email questions to answer that relate to the subject.
So let's get started, shall we?
Yeah, I think we shall.
Scoutmastership in seven minutes or less.
If a group of scouters get together
and they're going to spend a few hours together on a camping trip or something like that,
and they've got time to sit around and talk,
that talk will eventually turn to the question of what makes an eagle-scout,
And I am going to give you the answer.
That's right.
This often discussed, much debated question has one simple answer:
What makes an eagle-scout is a scout completes the requirements
issued by the Boy Scouts of America
and is approved by a duly constituted board of review.
That's what makes an eagle-scout.
There's nothing more to it.
That is it.
So what about this often discussed and argued qualities
of an eagle-scout, like maturity and leadership ability
and active service and all of those things?
All of these are embodied in the requirements,
but they aren't requirements in and of themselves.
So let's take a look at maturity first.
There's quite a laundry list of things that indicate
the maturity of an eagle candidate.
If he's made it to a board of review for eagle-scout,
that means he's had the following experiences:
He's earned 21 merit badges at a minimum.
He served a minimum of 16 months in a position of responsibility.
He's been camping for a bare minimum of at least 24 nights.
He's proposed, planned and carried out an eagle service project
and he's had a minimum of seven scoutmaster conferences
and five boards of review.
Now, it's theoretically possible that a scout could hoodwink
all of his merit badge counselors,
all the members of his boards of review
and all the scouts and leaders who signed off
on his advancement requirements
and the scoutmaster at all of those scoutmaster conferences.
It is theoretically possible that he could somehow
surreptitiously convince them that he was a mature young man.
but there are many theoretical possibilities in life
and few of them are likely.
There are heated arguments sometimes over the chronological age
of an eagle candidate.
Some people think he's too young,
Some people think he's too old.
It's not important.
You should know by now that age and maturity
do not always go hand in hand.
I mean, if you've been listening to these podcasts,
that should be clear. I'm older than you
And oh well, you get the idea.
How about leadership ability?
Well, to get to an eagle board of review,
a scout has held positions of responsibility
for a minimum of 16 months.
He may have been a great leader,
He may have been very responsible,
He may have been somewhat less than the ideal leader
and he may have been somewhat less than ideally responsible.
If he's skated by doing a lackluster job,
that's not the fault of the candidate
so much as a failure of the leadership
that is supposed to be overseeing his work.
16 months is plenty of time to discuss
and mentor and coach and cajole
and encourage and train any scout.
If he hasn't shown up,
if he hasn't done what he's supposed to do
and we haven't taken action,
it's unconscionably unfair to ambush him
and say that his tenure in a position of responsibility
is not satisfactory.
How about active service?
Well, how can a scout do the things
that we've talked about
without being actively involved in scouts?
There's much more heat than light
in most discussions about what it means to be active.
I have the antidote for that.
There's very specific guidance about this
in the Guide to Advancement.
I'm not going to go into it now,
but there's a three-level test
for determining if a scout is active or not
and the view from a thousand feet. on that test,
it's determined that he's satisfied
the expectations of his unit.
He's done, and then there are other alternatives
if it is determined that somehow
he has not satisfied the expectations of his unit.
Check it out in the Guide to Advancement.
It's very clear and it's very easy to follow.
What about the often stated undue influence
of parents on an Eagle candidate?
I've had the privilege of presenting more than 50
and somewhat less than 100 Eagle badges.
To tell you the truth, I really lost count right around 40..
Of those scouts, of those somewhere between 50 and 100 scouts,
two may have had more help from their parents
than I would have liked,
But it didn't devalue becoming an Eagle scout.
It wasn't some tragic miscarriage of justice.
I would have just liked those particular parents
to back off for a little bit
and let the poor scout breathe.
You know what I'm saying.
It is theoretically possible that parents can step in
and do all the work for the scout,
write his proposals and his reports.
It's a theoretical possibility
but I've never seen it happen.
I've seen parents be a little overheated about this,
be a little over-involved about it
kind of helicopter around.
I wish they wouldn't,
But to my lights it did not seriously impact
the value of the process that the scout went through
towards becoming an Eagle.
Every scout who's ever earned the rank of Eagle
did it individually
and in the opinion of the people he was working with,
he met the requirements at that time.
So right now we've had a million plus
scouts become Eagle scouts
throughout the history of the Boy Scouts of America
And I will bet that in the case of at least half of them,
someone thought they probably didn't deserve it,
Or they were at least a little skeptical
about whether or not that particular scout
had achieved- really really achieved-
becoming an Eagle scout.
Our district advancement chair is an old
scouting buddy of mine
and he regularly gets phone calls or emails
that cast doubts on the suitability
of a particular Eagle candidate
And his reply to the people who bring these concerns to him
is that they can appear at the border review
or they can prepare a letter to send to the border review.
but he is not the messenger
and he will certainly not permit anonymous accusations.
He tells me that nine out of 10 people
never follow up.
They are never convinced enough
to follow themselves and represent these concerns.
Now I've been around for a while
but I can tell you, as a younger scout master
I used to chase my tail about these things
with just about every Eagle candidate.
I used to look at the requirements
and think that they were just too simple,
that they should be tougher,
that we should aim higher.
We all have- we all have-
some idealized conceptualization
of what we think an Eagle scout would be.
You have my ideal Eagle scout.
You have your ideal Eagle scout.
I think it's better that we understand
the wisdom of simple universal requirements
that are applied on an individual basis,
where the final say is left up to a border review.
who understand the award
and make a final judgment?
I'll talk about this in the answer to an email in a moment.
I have a hobby about griping about
the quality of the work a scout does
since 1910..
We've been at it for a century.
We've suspected that there are
scouts getting away with something
and that they have not risen to our idealized model.
But I have to tell you something:
every Eagle award I've ever presented
was created by the Boy Scouts of America.
I never embroidered an Eagle insignia
or hand forged an Eagle medal.
It's not my award to protect
unworthy opponents.
And finally, I think that there is
way too much danks over the
quote quality,
unquote of Eagle Scouts,
when what really needs attention
is not the quality of work done by scouts
but the quality of attitude,
understanding and motivations
of the adults that work with them.
10,, 9,, 8,, 7,,
6,, 5, 4, 3,
2, 1, let's start the fun.
Oh,
Email, that is folks.
And here's an answer to one
of your emails.
This email came to me
and the person in the Senate
requested that I withhold their name,
but they wrote to say this:
I've thoroughly enjoyed your website
and podcast. They were pointed out to me
by a fellow scouter in my son's
Cub Scout pack.
I think you provide a common sense
of scouting that sometimes gets lost
by well-meaning adults.
I have been involved with scouting
as an adult volunteer for the past
seven years. I've been a den leader
and assistant Cub Master and a Cub Master.
I'm now our pack committee chair.
I also serve as the advancement chair
for my older son's troop.
I've tried to educate myself
as much as I can with the training
offered, both online and in person.
I've been to many training events
and Scout University and all that sort of thing.
Recently, several Scouts
in our troop completed the Eagle Scout
rank. Several of us
are beginning to form the opinion that
some of the requirements are being
signed off without being completed.
One Scout was three
days away from his 18th birthday
when I received a call
from his Eagle Coach to get his Merit Badge
record. As we've reviewed
the records we found that he was one
elective short. I was told
a short time later that he was going to
be doing the Sports Merit Badge.
that very evening The Eagle Coach
said he was going to sign up to be a
Sports Merit Badge counselor.
counsel the badge with the Scout that evening
and then the Scout would bring me
the blue card later on.
And the Scout did deliver the blue card,
signed by the new Merit Badge
counselor and the Scout Master,
later that evening. I did what I do
with any Merit Badge card: I accepted
it and I recorded it. I looked at the
requirements for Sports Merit Badge
and I doubt he could have completed
all of the requirements in one
meeting in one evening
with a Merit Badge counselor. It bothered
me for a day or two and I discussed it
with our troop committee chair and made
him aware of these concerns.
Here's what I'd like to know: What should I have done?
What could I have done? This
just doesn't sit right. It would be
tragic if a Scout ran out of time, but
if they didn't complete the requirements they don't
earn the rank. I think the Eagle Coach
and our Scout Master kind of enabled
this Scout and pencil whip to the
requirements. I would value your
opinion on the question. Thanks for your time
and keep up the great work. Well,
first of all, thanks for the kind comments
and, as always, I'm glad to hear folks
find what I do useful.
What you relate is a fairly
familiar story, so let me offer you
some advice that maybe can help
you handle the situation. First,
to gain a little perspective: 99
times out of 100 things go well with
advancement and Scouts roll right along
with everything's done. Once in a while
we run into situations like the ones that
you described. Specifically, there's
one way of parsing the sports
merit badge requirements. for a Scout
who's been active in a sport previously,
that may have satisfied the counselor
in one evening. I've seen this
happen before. I don't think it's
a proper interpretation of the
requirements. but I'm not the counselor.
I didn't discuss this with the Scout
and I didn't sign the blue card, and
neither did you. So you did
what every responsible advancement chair
should do. You accepted the blue card
at face value, you registered
the advancement, but at the same
time you've got one eye open
looking for the sort of thing
that made you uncomfortable,
And I think you probably
understood that. you are in a position
to correct the counselor or to
question his signature, and I'm going to encourage you
to be very happy about that.
You aren't the arbiter of who did
what and whether or not they should
receive credit for it.
That is up to the merit badge counselor
or the person who signs
any rank requirement. That signature
is never questioned because that's how
we handle an advancement
system based on honor
and trust. If we started
questioning every signature
and retesting every requirement,
we undermined this system
of honor and trust. The
problem with the system of honor and trust
is that human beings are involved.
So every
once in a while, you're going to have
a good fifth suspicion that something
has gone wrong If,
after some thought, you are still
convinced that something was
shortcut or something wasn't
proper. We don't argue
with the merit badge counselor and
we certainly don't penalize a scout
because he was basically doing
what he was told to do. So
in this case, you go to
the folks who register merit badge
counselors and you make them aware of this
situation, and I would just
note that calling
on the telephone or having
a face-to-face conversation is always
preferable to emailing.
Don't make emails out of these
kinds of situations, because emails take
on a life of their own. Talk to
the person. Tell the district
or council advancement chairman
exactly what you've told me in this email,
but include the names and the dates,
and then that puts the ball
in their court where it belongs.
They're the ones who certify
merit badge counselors,
not you. So one
cardinal rule is that
scouts do not suffer from mistakes
made by adults, because they have
little control over what adults
do. Hopefully, in the eventual
resolution of the situation you're describing,
the scout won't be made to suffer.
Now, as I mentioned earlier in this podcast,
the day after
the first Eagle Scout got his badge,
someone somewhere started complaining
about pencil whipping and shortcuts,
and I'm going to tell you
and everybody who's listening, in the
best spirit of friendship
and in the spirit of one who shares
the same concerns, that
that kind of attitude is not
productive or helpful in the
least. We scouters can make
a hobby out of being preoccupied
with things that go wrong
and we form clubs of
moaners and groaners, and I know this
because I was the founding member of a couple.
If there
are serious problems with the
advancement program in our troops,
we start working towards
correcting them. Scouters can form
bad habits, just like anybody else,
but these can be fixed
with some training and counseling
from a knowledgeable person,
that makes a big difference. The
attitude in which you do that is the
spirit of a helpful brother rather
than just a nitpicking.
Now, there's no accusation
intended there. It's a
tall order for anyone
who finds something like this and finds
it upsetting to maintain
the right spirit and the right attitude.
but you'll find if you do that,
things get better faster.
So when it comes to advancement,
we leave the judgment
to the person who signs
the requirement and any
improprieties that come to light
you address them by talking to the people
who can actually do something about it.
and then we go around
shedding as much light as we can on the whole
affair rather than cursing the darkness.
I'll tell you, in my troop
patrol leaders sign 99%
of the advancement requirements up to
first class. When I have a scout
masters conference I do a quick
spot check on this. I'm not
questioning signatures, I'm not
retesting requirements.
I just pick out a requirement
at random and I ask a scout
to describe to me how he got
that requirement signed off.
every so often- not
commonly, but every so often-
I'm dissatisfied with the answer
that the scout gives me and I
note who signed the requirement
once the scout masters conference is over,
I go to the youth leader
that signed the requirement.
I ask him to describe to me exactly
what happened and I encourage him
to read the requirement very carefully.
that moment of
realization, that aha moment, usually
follows when the scout who signs
understands that maybe
he didn't do it properly.
I encourage him to do better.
I may even ask if he thinks he should go over that
particular requirement with the scout again,
just to make sure that the scout
really understands what's going on.
I don't penalize the scout who
had his book signed for somebody else's
mistake. that just wouldn't be
fair. Now listen, I'm
a nitpicker. I get exercised
and I see something out of line in my own troop,
so I understand how uncomfortable
this sort of thing can feel.
thankfully, after years of
concentrated practice,
I don't make a fool of myself more than
once or twice a week now, so
I truly hope
that helps. The next email
also makes it to the podcast
anonymously and they wrote in to say this:
we're a fairly new troop
and we're still refining our understanding
of positions. as far as the
Eagle application goes,
what should each adult review
before signing the Eagle application?
who reviews scout spirit, the scout oath
ranks, merit badges, project references
and all that. Is it the scout master?
is it the committee chair, the district
chair? do we all review everything
or do each of us specialize?
Well, actually it's very simple.
if you look at the Eagle rank
application, once the
scouts completed the requirements,
including the scout masters conference,
the application and you have the scout
and the scout master in the committee chair sign it.
you don't end up reviewing anything
other than your advancement records to fill out
the application. The folks at the Eagle
border review take care of assessing
the candidate. You're just supplying
the information that they need to do that
in a responsible manner. Now I sent
that answer to the author
of the email and they replied
with this: what if the committee chair thinks
it's his job to assess scout spirit
in active status and tells
the scout they have to attend
X number of meetings and Y number
of outings and Z number of summer camps,
or he's not going to sign the application?
I thought this committee chair
was strictly administrative, reviewing the accuracy
of records and paperwork,
but our committee chair seems to think
he has a broader role.
Well, from time to
time this sort of thing happens
and frankly, it's a shame that
an adult would do such a thing
and in the case of this committee chair,
I think a little training and
a little study
would help them better understand their role
in the Eagle Scout process.
If there's absolutely no reasoning
with the committee chair, then the scout
and his parents can request a border
review under disputed
circumstances. You find directions
on how to do this
in the Guide to Advancement 2013
in section
everybody got their pencils ready-
8.0.3.2,
entitled
initiating an Eagle Scout border
review under disputed circumstances.
Now, this is
only available for the Eagle Scout rank.
it's held at the district or council level
and volunteers
from the candidates unit
are not involved. If a
unit leader or committee chair
does not agree that a scout's met the requirements
before a border review is held,
you know, step one is
they should meet with the scout-
the scout's parents perhaps-
and come to an understanding of all the viewpoints
and see what they can work out.
They should maybe talk to their district
or council advancement chair
to make sure that their expectations are not
more than are actually required.
but if that person remains unconvinced
and they don't want to sign
the Eagle Scout rank application,
if that's the case, the application is returned
to the scout or his parent or guardian
and they write a letter
that explains the
circumstances and they
request a border review
under disputed circumstances.
you attach that letter
to the completed Eagle Scout application
and you send it with the service project
workbook to the council service center.
now the council advancement chair
or staff advisor or other designated
volunteer notifies
the unit leader and the unit committee
that the request has been received
and they guide the process through the council
or district advancement committee according to
the practices that have been established locally.
that border review meets
and the unit leader
or committee chair is informed of their decision,
and that's the way that that works.
border review under disputed
circumstances should not be a routine procedure.
it is there to
resolve issues
when a scout
or their parents feel
that they will not get a fair hearing
from their own unit,
and that may be the course of action that you need to take
if it turns out that
the situation you describe
simply can't be resolved any other way.
I hope that helps.
and three is the charm when it comes to everything,
including emails, which people
do not want to have their names mentioned.
so this final email
for today's podcast
comes from someone who asks:
I've been asked to help staff a council event
that will teach scout skills for scouts
through first class rank
after being a file of your podcast for a long time.
this kind of makes me uneasy.
I can't find where such an event
is prohibited in the guide to advancement,
but to me this isn't in the spirit
of the patrol method.
just having an event for a day
where scouts learn a bunch of scout skills,
with the obvious
goal being that they're going to get them signed off,
makes me feel a little queasy.
so I have three questions for you.
is this kind of thing permissible
under BSA rules?
do you think Baden Powell would approve of it,
and how can I tactfully
turn down the request for me
to get involved with it?
I don't know about the details of the proposed event,
but if it's as you describe,
I kind of agree with your assessment.
for all its good intentions,
I don't think it's consistent with the patrol method of youth leadership.
advancement is something that happens naturally
through applying the patrol system,
you know, by just doing what scouts do.
I don't think that we
accomplish very much by holding events
intended to check things off a list.
if you separate the requirements
from the patrol experience,
you kind of take all the life out of them
and you just end up with this list of things to do.
now. the guide to advancement
doesn't prohibit every wrong headed approach.
it describes the right way
and leaves the rest to training
and common sense.
when the guide to advancement describes
the right approach, it says this:
a scout advances from tender foot to eagle
by doing things with his patrol
and troop, with his leaders
and on his own.
a well rounded and active unit
program that generates advancement
as a natural outcome
should take boys to first class
in their first 12 to 18 months.
it also says: a scout learns
by doing and as he learns
he grows in his ability to do his part
as a member of the patrol
and troop. as he develops knowledge
and skill, he's asked to teach others,
and this way
he learns and develops leadership.
so it's not that we're looking for prohibitions,
as much as you know,
looking for the right way to go.
would Baden Powell approve of this?
well, I haven't spoken to him
in a long time,
but I think it's pretty easy to tell
what his attitude would be by reading what he's written.
he said once:
the patrol system is the one
essential feature in which scout training
differs from that of all other
organizations. where the system
is properly applied,
it is absolutely bound to bring success.
it can't help itself.
the formation of boys into patrols
of six to eight
and training them as separate units,
each under their own responsible leader,
is the key to a good troop.
the patrol is the unit of scouting. always,
whether for work,
for play, for discipline or duty,
an invaluable step in character training
is to put responsibility
onto the individual.
this is immediately gained
when a patrol leader becomes responsible
for the command of his patrol.
it is up to him to take hold
of and develop the qualities of
each scout in his patrol.
it sounds a big order,
but in practice it works.
Baden Powell usually wrote
about what works and he didn't
describe every single practice. that wouldn't
work. but if we pay attention to what works,
we don't have to worry about what doesn't.
now, how do you bow out of
an invitation like this?
I think you tell the folks that ask you
that your study and training tell you
this really isn't the best road to go,
that we don't gather scouts together
in big herds and teach them skills
that scouts learn and achieve
in the context of the patrol.
that a well rounded and active
unit program that generates
advancement as a natural outcome
should take boys to first class
in their first 12 to 18 months
of membership. let me tell you this:
you've got a good eye
and you played that well. you've caught the spirit
of scouting and, let's be honest,
you really already knew the answer I was
going to give you, didn't you?
I'm happy to answer your email questions,
and you can get in touch with me
and we'll find out how to do that in just a moment.
well, thanks for listening
to the 194th edition
of the scout master podcast.
all of the past editions of the podcast
are available for download or listening
on our podcast archive
at scoutmastercgcom.
while you're there, you can join over
2,500 email subscribers
and receive updates to the blog by email.
you can also subscribe to the scoutmaster
podcast on iTunes
or access the podcast on your mobile device
through Stitcher Smart Radio.
you can get details about how to make that happen
at stitchercom.
you can experience all the wonders
of scoutmastercgcom
and help spread the word through the vast
panorama of social media
outlets. join over
4,300 folks who follow us
at scoutmaster blog on facebook.
join our 850 plus
twitter followers at scoutmastercg
on twitter and subscribe
to watch us at scoutmastercg
on youtube.
you can also join the 1,000 plus
in the exclusive scoutmastercg
circle by searching for
scoutmastercg
on google plus.
if you're anti-social media,
if none of that appeals to you,
that's alright. bunkie,
fly into the late 90s
and email me
your comments, questions and wild ideas.
my email address is
clark at scoutmastercgcom.
at clark
at
scoutmastercgcom.
the scoutmaster blog
and the scoutmaster podcast
are in no way official publications
of the Boy Scouts of America
and they are not endorsed or sponsored
by the Boy Scouts of America.
it's just me talking into a microphone
and trying to lend a hand to scout leaders
and have a little bit of fun as we do so.
as always, we close this podcast
with a word from our founder,
Sir Robert Baden Powell.
Sir Robert, good luck to you
and good camping.
why? thank you, sir,
until next time.